[Music]
is there anybody else out there besides
us why should we be interested in
finding life elsewhere
these are the questions raised by dr
bill stone
explorer caver inventor of a new class
of robot called cryobots
there are a number of moons out there
called ocean worlds
stone is building his cryobots with nasa
for unmanned exploration in space
nearly 400 million miles from earth
there's a reasonable chance that we
could find microbial life in those
oceans
simple celled single-celled multi-celled
preachers could that exist on other
worlds
the team he's assembled spends years
testing these robots in earth's most
extreme environments try to take science
fiction and turn it into science fact by
the time the trip is scheduled his
cryobots will be ready to search for
life across the galaxy
i was 14 when neil armstrong and buzz
aldrin landed on the moon
i wanted to be just like those guys i
wanted to be an astronaut i wanted to go
to the moon and beyond i went through
college grad school and a phd program
thinking all along that i was going to
join the astronaut corps and we were
going to go back to the moon
i was not selected i was told i was too
independent
which
but that's okay because i've since gone
on to do work related to private space
exploration and exploration here on
earth in very deep caves
some of our crews have been to the
deepest places inside this planet that
anybody has ever been
and
distances so remote that it takes more
time to get there than it would to get
to the moon by rocket
so to me that's kind of where i really
find life everything else in between is
just preparing for that
i founded stone aerospace about 15 years
ago with the idea of putting together a
collection of very talented individuals
who could take on difficult scientific
problems and turn them into reality
[Music]
a lot of the stuff that we do involves
expeditionary type work to places where
it's difficult to get to and requires
technology to do things there
europa is one of the gala land moons of
jupiter it is entirely covered with ice
and that ice is
over an ocean of significant depth
[Music]
to me it's a very interesting
philosophical question you know is there
life other than earth and here's a
chance within our lifetime to prove it
one way or another
the best place that we can get on earth
right now that is kind of like europa is
the antarctic ice shelf
that has depths of ice of up to 4 000
meters
over subglacial lakes if we could build
a device that would go through
4 000 meters of ice in antarctica we
would be paving the way
to enabling a europa mission
a cryobot is a general term for
what some people would refer to as a
melt probe or an ice penetrator
this is valkyrie this is the world's
first laser powered cryobot
this entire thing right here is a closed
cycle hot water drill
[Music]
[Applause]
the purpose of a cryobot is to get
through the ice but once you get there
what do you do well the idea is to
deliver an autonomous underwater vehicle
that goes looking for life
artemis is a
hovering autonomous underwater vehicle
it was built to test ideas for how to
explore
long ranges under
an ice cap
[Music]
and to investigate ways in which you
would look for life in environments like
that
[Music]
we've been to antarctica three times now
i've spent almost a year there with our
crews
there is a really large suite of
scientific sensors on this vehicle
everything from
five high definition cameras to
water uh collection systems we can
measure ocean currents
so i'm getting a line that way
and we can tell with tracking antennas
where the vehicle is moving below the
ice cap even if it's hundreds of meters
below the ice
this is the first one in which we've had
a vehicle where you drill through an ice
cap and then send it off for long
distances on its own and have it come
back and actually
dock latch and be automatically
pulled to the surface
so this is really a prototype for a
long-range europa sub-ice
carrier vehicle what we would refer to
as the mothership something that would
be able to create
topographical maps of the core of europa
for example
it
requires onboard
intelligence at a level which we have
never
deployed yet not even for example with
curiosity on mars right now
[Music]
so the robots will have to be much more
independent than they are today and they
will have very specific roles in what
they need to do
could we pull off a europa mission to
the subsurface ocean answer is
absolutely yes 100 yes
i believe that it is launchable within
10 years if the money was on the table
today
there's two things i think that drive us
one is the pursuit of happiness and the
second one is the pursuit of curiosity
if galileo had not been interested in
the motions of planets or copernicus or
kepler
who would have provided the information
that allowed newton to figure out the
law of gravitation
these little things
are revelations about the universe about
us our place in it
how could you not find satisfaction
in solving those curious problems
you